welcome back to 820 special relativity
in this section we talk about space time
diagrams
they turn out to be very useful tools to
describe
events or sequences of events in
particular when observed by multiple
observers
so what is the space-time diagram
here's an example
you have an x-coordinate and a
t-coordinate for space and time
i plotted an event
in blue here and the word line of events
a word line is just the sequence of
events as they occur
um in this case um something seemed to
be moving with constant velocity the
world line is just the continuous line
velocity of this event is delta x over
delta t which is one over the slope
let's have a look here so the time axis
is defined as those events
which all occur at the same space x
equals zero
while the x-axis is defined as those
events which all occur simultaneously at
the same time
and then you can draw
additional lines into
the time space time diagram where for
example all times are equal to one you
might want to add a unit i omitted this
here uh time might be given in seconds
in days in hours and years
however you like similar to space in
meters or light years
so lines here in green
of the same time meaning time is
constant they happen all events on that
line happen simultaneously
while in blue are those lines where
events happen at the same location so x
is equal constant some specific values
um
here in red i add one additional caveat
which you are typically not aware or
considering very much
in diagrams is the role of tick marks
here in this space-time diagram all tick
marks are perpendicular to the axis
it's also okay or correct here to say
that they're in parallel to the second
axis and we'll come back to this point
later on
an example
um of a word line is simply you know
drawing all events which correspond to
me right professor is pacing in his
office um
you know maybe on a line just the x
coordinate is plotted here time passes
and i'm just placing the long changing
direction each time each little segment
with constant velocity that's the word
line of me from some time t equal minus
t to term time equal 40.
okay so now a first concept question
let's consider
those
the set of word lines one two three four
and the question is which of the objects
which correspond to the word line is
moving the slowest
so let's consider this for a second and
then we look at this
as the velocity is one over the slope
the object that says steepest slope
largest value of the slope is moving the
slowest and in this case it's object
number two
all right now we want to actually make
them useful
yes they can be used in order to
describe certain event lines but they're
really use useful when you describe
events happening for a different
observer
so in this activity i invite you to draw
bob's base time diagram into analysis
and then as a second step draw alice's
space-time diagram into bobs
the situation is very similar to
previous ones discussed in this lecture
alice is stationary and bob moving in
this rocket with a velocity of half the
speed of life light or a gamma factor of
1.2
all right
try go ahead just try to to
show where is the time axis for bob
and where is the spatial coordinate for
bob
okay so the way to approach this is the
following we're going to use lawrence
transformations
in order to figure out what is the value
um
of bob's um
time axis and space space access
for different values of alice's
space-time diagram so we start with
drawing alice's space-time diagram and
then if you want to find the x-axis as
seen by bob we have to set the time
for bob to equal zero
and then
find the corresponding
elements or tick marks on the axis so
the first point we want to find is t b
equals zero
and t b at x e x b equal one
so with the lawrence transformation we
find that x a one
so this point corresponds in alice's
base time diagram to
xa equal gamma equal 1.2 and t a equal
gamma times v over c c square equal 0.6
so we can make this
find this first point and plot it in our
diagram
it's right here
okay and then we move around and find
the second point and the third point and
we do the same for the time axis
where xb is equal to zero and tb equal
one then corresponds to
0.6 in x a1 and 1.2 in xa2 so we find
these points here
i failed to say that the origin of those
two
space-time diagrams currencies
okay
so this is already it so we found found
bob's time axis where xb is equal to
zero and bob's
x-axis where tb is equal 0. and i did
draw those
the stick marks
parallel to the second axis so if i want
to now find out
the time axis for x b equal one i just
have to follow along and draw a parallel
um in the picture here
all right so the second question then is
where is alice's where alice's axis in
bob's space time direction so the
procedure is very similar as before we
draw alice's axis
sorry we draw bob's axis and we find
alex's axis x
x-axis by setting t a equals zero and
then we find the number of points
and connect those and the time axis is
found by setting
x a equals zero and finding then uh
points for various values of time
and you see here this looks a little
different than before i just zoom in
here a little bit um what you find
specifically because relative the
direction of motion changes the positive
values of x
are
in
[Music]
positive values
uh in negative
the positive values of the x-axis
are in the negative time direction where
the negative values of x are in the
positive times the time direction should
be across bending here so this needs a
little bit to get used to but you will
later see by now draw
in
any of the two space-time diagrams
specific sequence of events i can
immediately read off
how this event is perceived from bob's
and from alice's perspective and this
makes those space tag from very very
useful tools
you